hi everybody this is jonathan trance and
today i have a tactical puzzle for you
so when you see the tactic on your
screen go ahead and pause your video and
see if you can solve it alright so in
this position it's white to move okay I
hope you weren't tempted into playing
the move Bishop takes h6 which does
indeed remove the defender of the night
but after the Queen takes black is able
to liquidate a lot of pieces here he can
trade the Knights and after either
recapture either with the rook or the
Queen black can consider taking on b2 or
you can consider trading more pieces
with Queen to d8 and in either case
material is equal so what didn't
accomplish everything that he was trying
to do so we'll go back for a second
now the actual solution to this puzzle
is the brilliant Queen takes f6 check
and after the King takes the Queen now
we're set up for a brilliant night fork
the knight takes on d7 forking two
pieces now whichever way the King
retreats white picks up the Queen and
he's won a piece in the process I hope
you enjoyed this video congratulations
to those of you they're able to get the
puzzle correct and hopefully i stumped a
few of you if you'd like to see more
videos like this please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you for watching